[Applause]
comfortable with the applause because
I'm thinking why are we applauding about
mental health but you raised a really
interesting point that it is we are
really here to celebrate and have a
conversation that most people don't
we're breaking the silence applauses to
support all exactly support this effort
it really is just to support all of us
today as you've just heard mental health
is an issue it concerns all of us nearly
48 million listen to that number 48
million US adults experienced a mental
illness in 2018 alone mental health
disorders are real medical conditions
just like cancer or diabetes they can
change a person's emotions your thinking
your behavior and are caused by a
variety of factors including genetics
lifestyle and certainly the environment
yet misunderstandings about mental
health disorders are still common a new
CBS News poll finds 51 percent of
Americans think there's a lot of
discrimination and stigma against people
living with mental illness an additional
35 percent believe there is some and
those numbers are too high in preparing
this special we've consulted with the
National Alliance on Mental Illness the
American Psychiatric Association and a
brain research group known as one mind
all of them for editorial guidance we
did not do this alone
and we'll hear from some of their
leading experts throughout our show and
while this is only one hour and it will
only scratch the surface of topics
surrounding mental health CBS this
morning and all of us are committed to
continued coverage of this important
issue our mission this morning is clear
and it is simple it is time to stop the
stigma queer I star that's Kurama was
one person trying to do exactly that
he's on the hit show that he's known for
helping other people work through their
own emotions you do need support for
mentally
I think you feel so supported if people
just knew that no it's not that I'm
shutting off I'm just trying to get
myself together yep might be trying to
talk to them that's the key thing you're
not alone in this team I'm ready severe
depression anxiety and drug addiction
that's helped him become an advocate for
mental health care amo we thank you for
joining us
of course I'm excited to be here we're
excited to have you here because you
were telling me that this happened back
in in high school you started having
very dark feelings what did that feel
like what did that look like to you
you know for me it was waking up and
feeling like the Sun just wasn't shining
as bright as the day before and it kept
getting darker each day and yet I
couldn't understand why and I was
sharing with you backstage I went to my
parents not understanding and having the
language what's happening - yeah what's
going on with me and my mother and
father were just I pray it away pray you
know God will help you and I do believe
there's a space for prayer but I also
believe that there's also a space for
finding help right here but what do you
do when you can't find that house it
started as far back as high school and
it at its worst what did it feel like um
it felt like I can't get out of bed as
if I was alone as if things were not
gonna get better
as if like the smallest task felt
overwhelming and as if I had a large
weight on my shoulder and that just
progressively got worse and worse and
worse
and what was a turning point light
because really the show is about those
turning points where you said I need
help or someone came to you and said we
can help you
yep for me it was at the point of
realizing that I needed to live a better
life I wanted to have a better life and
it was really seeing people in spaces
like this which is why I applaud
everyone this audience where I said you
know what if they're trying to be better
maybe I can be better too and so I just
started to try to find the help educate
myself find support systems and that was
the first time you said you didn't even
know you could get help you didn't even
think that that was an option to you
Ono's yeah not at all I thought that
mental health support was for rich
people you know I didn't grow up well
rich white people rich white people and
it'd be very
you know because watching television I
saw only rich white girls going to rehab
and getting support is it's what I
thought you know everyone anyone who
looked like me I never saw them seeking
mental health support or talking about
their mental health let's let's get a
question from our Emmie is 24 years old
she struggled to talk with her family
members about her experience with eating
disorder and addiction Remy Remy what's
your question hi Corrado my question is
what tips you have for those who are
struggling with mental health that come
from cultural backgrounds that don't
typically encourage speaking out about
it first of all I want to dis applaud
you for being so open about your
struggle thank you so much that's really
great one of the main things that we
have to remember communities of colors
or people of immigrants they sometimes
don't have the information there's a
lack of information there's also a lack
of access to health care and so we have
to understand all those factors play
into why they're not talking about
mental health and why it's not important
to them in a sense and so giving them
the education that they need is really
key in steps so for you getting to a
place where you feel comfortable it's
about educating them to let them know
that the same way if I had a physical
room mom and dad you would want me to
tend to that every single day let them
know the physical wound is in my mind or
in my heart and that's a way to help
them to understand that and needs just
as much attention things remain you've
also talked about members of the LG
few community have a higher rate of
suicide attempts than the general
population you yourself said that you
had tried to take your own life yeah
years ago I did is your message about
that you know when it comes to the LGBT
community a lot of us suffer bullying
we've suffered rejection causes we
suffered depression anxiety and so you
have to remember that in the LGBT
community again you're already feeling
isolated from your family or groups of
support so where do you turn when you
feel like this and for me it was
important to make sure that I reach back
out to LGBTQ I youth I worked in social
services for many years helping those
youth to understand there is a place and
there is support for them that they
don't have to live in this dark cloud
every day that they can get help but you
thought taking your life was a viable
alternative for you I did you know once
you got that dark yeah it did get that
dark for me you know i sat there one day
and thought this is never gonna get
better and I'm someone who was educated
and understood mental health and could
help other people but couldn't help
myself in a moment and want to get
another question from the audience will
was diagnosed with depression when he
was a sophomore in high school will
what's your question I have found that
regularly checking with my family like
my mom here yeah as well as daily
meditations in writing have been crucial
to my mental health
what other daily routines have helped
you really great question thank you
again for you for being open one of the
things that I help people to realize is
that the same way you set goals for your
life of I the career I want the family I
want also set daily emotional goals so
for me I wake up in the morning and I
say today I plan on being happy and if
there's things that are happening in my
life where I don't see myself being
happy I try to find support from other
people or I try to figure out what I can
do with it myself with education I can
get and I think that's really important
because when we talk about our emotions
we think of them as this ambiguous thing
that's happening or like if I want a
good year as if like everyday something
doesn't happen that changes that quickly
give us the winnie pooh 20 the Pooh
advice you love a great spiritual leader
leader I don't remember the quote
exactly but you
oh yeah I love this Winnie the Pooh here
here's what he said you are braver than
you believe stronger than you seem and
smarter than you think I'm oh thank you
very much like dailymotion of all the
National Suicide Prevention lifeline at
one eight hundred to seven three eight
to five five or contact the crisis text
line by texting talk to seven four one
seven four one and stay with us we have
much more ahead in our special stop the
stigma a growing number of adolescents
are being diagnosed with mental health
disorders we'll look at the warning
signs for parents and how young people
can get help plus emmy-winning broadcast
journalists and our colleague Jane
Pauley will share her experiences with
bipolar disorder and will talk to the
mother of Lady Gaga's Cynthia Germanotta
is her name she started the Born This
Way Foundation with her daughter who she
calls Stephanie the rest of us call her
gaga about the effects of mental illness
on family and friends but first it is
8:11 time to check your local weather
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
stop the stigma everyone deserves
authentic welcome and a place to belong
there's nothing completely wrong with
you you're completely we're calling it
as you've heard stop the stigma it's a
conversation about mental health we want
to make this a conversation an ongoing
conversation if you will to take away
the shame and the blame and that's
something emmy-winning broadcast
journalists and we're proud to say our
colleague Jane Pauley is very passionate
about after more than 30 years reporting
the news Polly put a very public face on
bipolar disorder she revealed that she
had taken a break from the spotlight and
spent three weeks in a psychiatric
clinic after being diagnosed back in
2001 and now here's the big picture an
estimated seven million Americans live
with bipolar disorder it's an illness
that can cause dramatic mood swings from
depressive lows to manic highs and Jane
is now an advocate for mental health as
well as the host of our beloved CBS
Sunday morning thank you thank you for
being you were diagnosed and I should
point out that the majority of people
who experience mental illness
experienced it and are diagnosed before
the age of 24 in your case you were 53
kids married successful career very busy
career what was it like to get the
diagnosis well when I was 49 I was not
bipolar when I was 50 I was I was
switched a flipped these are medical
terms of art I treated for hives
medication that wouldn't have been given
to someone at least without protection
and and careful observation if a doctor
had reason to think that there was
family history or prior history with a
mood disorder I didn't have that you had
no family history
that I know of you know yeah but it it
unmasked what doctors then described as
a genetic vulnerability yeah to a mood
disorder and by that time I was in
pretty deep trouble it's pretty
interesting that the in terms of
experiencing stigma one of the direct
ways that you did is your own doctor who
suggested maybe you don't want to tell
the public about this whole thing and
even gave you a little cover story I
want to tell talk about stigma a little
bit later when you tell me I can but the
only time in my life and it's been we're
closing in on 20 years that I
experienced stigma was that day day one
when I recognized that my doctor was
giving me a cover story to tell my
employers that I was being treated for a
thyroid disorder which was true but I
knew it was more than the whole truth
yeah and I poor guy I said you know I'm
already writing a book and the working
title is sky riding a life out of the
blue this will fit right in
he went pale but I knew then that with
my reputation on television I Western
normos are you surprised this happened
to you yes because I didn't know my
family had checked other boxes but not
that one itself you you wrote that the
only way to redeem this horrible
situation was to talk about that's the
way I think and and when I told this my
doctor he kind of turned pale and I
didn't put out a press release I
everybody deserves an opportunity to
recover from whatever in private yes
understand how it manifests itself for
you we keep hearing you were diagnosed
so how did it change for you what was a
difference if I changed I it didn't
change for me it actually got better I
the side-effect of of the steroids for
hives was anted anti what was depression
treated with antidepressant were you
said we're angry what was depression is
depression and then over time it worked
and I got better and felt much better
and then felt really great and then
started having plans and other behaviors
that my husband didn't know who I was so
that when I finally you know when the
doctor finally recognized oh I know
what's going on here mm-hmm this is bad
yeah he called my husband and he said
your wife is very sick and Gary was
almost relieved well maybe someone can
help get my wife back you don't like the
word stigma we're calling this program
yes it is my personal advocacy and I am
NOT an expert I'm someone with bipolar
don't take medical advice from me but as
a communicator I know something words
have power yes and the word stigma is
its own space its own stigma when you
you know cancer used to have a stigma
and then Betty Ford and then now we wear
pink ribbons and run for the Cure the
the yellow bracelets Michael J Fox
fights Parkinson's with hope with a
positive message so every time you say
stigma it is a reminder of people for
people like me that I'm fighting two
wars yeah it's not enough that I have a
disorder that's pretty serious
but I've also fighting this front so my
goal is that we fight stigma which is
real mm-hmm but we fight it with
sophistication and we normalized this
common goal yes it's a medical disorder
and there is good news word
out wearing ribbons and if there's a 5k
I'm sure everyone in this room would run
in it yeah Jane Pauley thank you very
much for being here we have a list of
mental health resources and guides
available on our website CBS this
morning dot-com slash mental health and
remember if you or someone you know is
ever experiencing a crisis you can call
911 up we talked to Cynthia Germanotta
Lady Gaga's mom about her daughter's
mental illness and the effects on the
family you're watching a very special
edition of CBS
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr. su bombers hirsute you were here we
just heard from Jane Pauley and Kurama
why is important for celebrities and
well-known people to speak out when
celebrities speak out two big things
happen number one is we pay attention
because we pay attention to people that
we like and that we respect and we get
educated and informed and number two
we've realized that they're not two
camps of people they're not people with
mental illness and then successful
people successful people often live with
mental illness so this can very much be
a part of our lives and we can thrive
and still be dealing with issues at the
same time they normalize and mainstream
the Congress all right sue Varma's can
stay with us we have war here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
special hour on CBS this morning I'm 22
copal I've got Gayle King here I've got
Anthony Mason here and we've got
everyone else in this studio we were
joined by a live studio audience as we
talked about a very important topic
mental illness mental wellness mount
wellness and mental health and the
journey between the three now get this
one in six young people experienced a
mental health disorder each year and the
suicide rate for adolescents aged 10 to
14 has nearly tripled in the last decade
think about that for a second a little
ten-year-old person up to 14 that's very
scary stuff me Anna Bryant was diagnosed
with depression back in college she
didn't know where to turn so she created
her own support group for college
students to talk with each other about
their mental health she called it I like
this name Jana the mental elephant
[Music]
extremely scared to tell my family and
to tell my parents that I've been
diagnosed with depression and that I was
asked to be put on medication I didn't
want people to lose respect for me or to
look at me or treat me any different
than how they normally would
hello everyone welcome to our reading
said the mental elephant began when I
first received my diagnosis we're for
everyone who is not okay but doesn't
know how to get back to the where they
want to be the main thing I like about
the mental elephant it just makes you
feel welcome first and foremost it just
helps people talk we do group chats we
do empowerment events we do study
sessions people understand like
counseling is okay I do talk about it
too like my friends sometimes what I'm
still working on that I know that there
are going to be days where you think
your world is collapsing there's going
to be moments where you're not even sure
how are you going to be able to get
through the current sixty Seconds so the
only thing that you on this earth 100%
have to do is breathe is the medical
director at the National Alliance on
Mental Illness one of our consultants
and a specialist in child and adolescent
psychiatry good morning to you both you
know that line you have at the end there
is very powerful sometimes you just got
to breathe what did putting this group
together how did that help you in the
end all this group of friends
it helped me by providing me with
insight on how other people might have
to go through life and the things that
they experienced in college but it also
provided me with support and it allowed
me to provide other people with support
and everyone knows that giving and
providing other people with help is
something that can even help you in the
long run and allow you to feel great on
the inside just at East Carolina this
group now is 300 strong yes sir we have
elephants all call
you say we have elephants all over I'm
assuming it you named it for the
elephant in the room which I think is
very very clever as well but something
that she yes ma'am so you're from the
south but Ken I thought she said
something very interesting that she was
reluctant to go to her parents and her
friends yeah because she didn't want
them to lose respect for her yeah that's
exactly why we're having this
conversation why we're delighted at Nami
that you're doing this yeah let me start
by saying me Ana's generation is
changing this game how so openness
vulnerability the willingness to share
things jnana is a beautiful example of
how the next generation you think we're
at a tipping point I think we are
absolutely at a tipping point in our
society people are talking about it
people are seeking help hardly a day
goes by so that somebody doesn't ask me
to connect them with a clinician but but
suicidal thoughts are going up among
young people yes first of time that's
right even as this generation is paving
the way for why is it going up Ken
social media is an opportunity to feel
humiliated every day yes yeah school
shooting drills should not be part of
sixth grade but they are in virtually
every school in America the design to
raise anxiety and we're losing five
Americans every hours our to the opiate
crisis Leone I'd use those kids know
somebody you sense a change at all in
your friends in terms of of the
reluctance in the past to talk about
this yes I would definitely say that
over the past at least two to three
years my friends and a lot of my family
members have become a lot more open and
honest and translucent when it comes to
their mental health and allowing me to
express myself and to think that I may
go through okay how do you tell the
difference I mean with all these people
you're talking to on a daily basis and
patients that you're seeing when does a
person know that they don't have
run-of-the-mill blues yes they have
something else that's gonna need a more
serious look at or more serious health
it's a great question Tony because all
of his experience anxiety all of us
experience sadness so it's easy to fall
into the trap of all you're just having
sadness or anxiety to snap out of it
that's the wrong way to think about it
when these symptoms impact your
functioning trouble going to work your
relationships that's
sign and they persist for weeks that's a
sign that you might want to get an
independent mental health evaluation
another piece is sleep if you're waking
up at 4 o'clock in the morning it's
quite likely that you either have an
anxiety or a depressive disorder not if
you get up to do the good morning let's
not miss your point is there anything
jnana that somebody could have said to
you that would have made a difference
when you were in the dark place I would
definitely say that the biggest thing
somebody could have said to me and I
would say to anyone now that may be in
that dark place is to keep breathing and
to quote my favorite movie Finding Nemo
just keep swimming just keep your head
up and try the best that you can no
matter what's going on Winnie the Pooh
and Finding Nemo having big roles yeah
one more thing for Ken you said we were
talking yesterday most people who have
attempted suicide who survived regret
that they tried it I think regret that
they try many people who've said during
an impulsive act moment of desperation
they wish they had ended it all and then
of course upon reflection they know that
they can get help yes it can and does
get better thank you both thank you both
and Lady Gaga's mother will join us with
her daughter's public advocacy and the
impact of mental illness on family and
friends but first a check of your local
weather
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and we got
so if you see somebody that's hurting
don't look away and if you're hurting
even though it might be hard try to find
that bravery within yourself to dive
deep and go tell somebody and take them
up in your head with you I love you
thank you so much of the Grammy Awards
the superstar has spoken openly about
dealing with mental illness including
depression anxiety and PTSD her mother
Cynthia Germanotta who looks just like
her rather Gaga looks like her mom joins
us now to talk about the impact of
mental illness on family and friends
Germanotta teamed up with her daughter
who she calls Stephanie that's her name
also known as Lady Gaga to the rest of
us to create the Born This Way
Foundation it works to educate people
about mental and emotional wellness
cynthia Germanotta thank you for joining
us very glad you for having me because
I'm inspired by you focusing on this
thank you we're delighted to do this you
know Gaga has talked very openly about
it and you were said you know when she
was a kid you always knew she was unique
when did it go from unique to Houston we
have a problem at your house well yeah
well first you know we all have mental
health but I believe that we as both
individuals in society we don't treat it
the same way that we treat physical
health yes so certainly when it happened
in our house I didn't know what to look
for as a parent I wasn't prepared to
really address this stephanie was very
unique and that wasn't always
appreciated by her peers and as a result
she went through a lot of difficult
times
humiliated taunted isolated when you're
a young woman this really severely
impacts you and it was in middle school
when I saw that turn happen you know
when she went from a very happy and
aspirational young girl to somebody that
started to question her self-worth to
have doubts about herself and and that
is when we actually saw the turn what I
didn't realize because I wasn't prepared
is how to really deal with it yeah when
I was growing up times were different
the way that we would deal with things
is what I learned and that's what I
resorted to you know I relied on get a
group I relied on getting a grip I
on the generational grit of just sucking
it up and getting on with it but even if
even if you you do learn to listen
sometimes it's still very hard and I've
been in this situation to know what to
do it's very hard to know what to do and
then the impact on families what I
didn't realize is the profound impact
that it can have it basically turns the
focus of everything onto that one
individual and families feel conflicted
about it they don't really understand it
it causes conflict and a lot of stress
within the families it can also cause
feelings for me personally feelings of
guilt of helplessness not knowing how to
help my daughter so what I really
learned is that no family is immune from
this we should all really learn all
really learn you know where we would go
and who we would turn to if something
like this happened in our families now
that you've been through it you've come
out the other side what advice or
recommendations you have to other people
who right now may have a family member
going through this very thing well one
of the most difficult things for me as a
parent was understanding what was normal
and what was not normal when you look at
young young children in particular you
know what is normal adolescent
development and then a real issue and
that for me was was not knowing how to
distinguish between certain both
emotional and behavioral changes you
know your emotions there's very
noticeable changes that happen feelings
of sadness feelings of feeling selfless
and worthless in terms of behavior you
might be more angry crying turning to
substance abuse yeah what wouldn't I
recommend yeah what's the most important
thing a parent can do well the most
important thing that they can do is is
really listen and understand what I
learned from my daughter is to listen
and validate her feelings I think as
parents our natural instinct is to go
into problem-solving mode yes no related
and in fact you know they really just
want us to take them seriously and
understand what they're saying and
sometimes they don't often want to talk
to their parents or talk to their peers
it's it important to find somebody that
they can talk to AP's they're not
talking to you we've learned from our
research that young people often don't
turn to their parents you know their
parents because they feel we get on
their nerves yes
there's fear of being judged yeah also
we as parents we don't talk about our
own struggles I encourage parents to be
vulnerable talk about your current or
past struggles so it really models
healthy conversations and and good
behavior both yes the biggest thing is
to really talk to them and it's it's
certainly okay to not be okay and start
to have these conversations right
Cynthia Germanotta thank you so much for
coming in experts about finding the
right health for you or your loved one
and remember if you or someone you know
is ever experiencing a crisis you can
call 911 a special edition
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mental health disorders are treatable
but last year nearly 57 percent of those
who needed treatment did not get it we
welcome back psychiatrist dr. Ken
Duckworth and dr. sue Varma along with
our own chief medical correspondent dr.
Jon LaPook good morning and you say
primary care doctors should be the first
line of defense in mental health yeah
and I think part of it is realizing that
assessing for mental health problems
that's in our Lane just as it's
assessing for a high blood pressure or
high cholesterol anything else is in our
Lane that means talking to people about
their mood about their possible mental
health problems but also looking for
clues so Ken mentioned earlier any
problems with sleep is the person
complaining of doing jittery or maybe
just a little bit of tired and then the
things that are more subtle so body
language right and what's really
important in assessing body language is
actually looking at the patient yeah so
if you turn away from that computer yeah
look at the person look them in the eye
and they'll feel safe and people want to
feel seen is so vital but but doctor
Varma medication is also out there it's
also an option what should people know
about that path medication is such an
important part can be an extremely -
effective tool as part of a
comprehensive treatment plan we need to
have realistic expectations we need to
know going in that medication takes time
to work if we're talking about an
antidepressant it may take six to eight
weeks it often has side effects dry
mouth constipation headaches most of
those side effects dissipate have a
scheduled follow-up appointment if it is
your primary care doctor that's treating
you to specifically discuss this a lot
of times people get lost to follow-up
they get get off their medication
because of the side effects and also
recognize that medication isn't gonna
solve all your problems if this if this
issue is due to a loss of depression due
to a family member getting lost or death
that we need to grieve those losses and
not throw medication at the person okay
let's go to Stuart in the audience he
has lived with anxiety for four decades
and more recently depression you have a
question for dr. Duckworth thank you my
question is around my family knew I was
depressed
but they didn't know how severe it had
become if somebody isn't forthcoming to
a psychiatrist or to their family how
can you help them Stuart that's a great
question because shame is a core human
emotion and if you're not feeling it
your best functioning at your best
there's a natural reticence to not share
a vulnerability one strategy is if you
happen to have a family history of
mental health have that discussion
before somebody develops a problem yeah
right that's one idea
the other idea is just to notice the
person and say you know is there
anything that you want to chat with me
about I noticed that you are depressed
I may not a flow of a full understanding
of what you're going through but I'm
open to listening to you very quickly
when do you know when to go to a
therapist
when you're functioning or safety is it
is in the is in the name of your
experience dr. Duckworth I think it's
important to tell people that they can
call their insurance company they have
an obligation to help you find a
therapist it's really important you can
get assistance in paying from best kept
secret in American mental health is your
health plan wants to find you a
therapist if you can't find one a secret
no more a secret no more your primary
care doctor is another route they often
are connected yeah there's a number on
the back of your insurance card thank
you very much dr. sue varmint ken
Duckworth and of course Jon LaPook we'll
see you at home later on thank you very
much if you're experiencing a mental
health crisis help is available that's
what we've been talking about this last
hour yeah and we are committed to
continuing our coverage of this
important issue all across CBS news
platforms thank you to our studio
audience and to our guests
[Applause]